I don't think these people have the
rights of excommunication I don't think
they have the right of representation
Stonewall is a racket it is a racket
that should have been shut down years
ago it operates like the mob it goes to
politicians and saying nice career
you've got here shame if anything
happened to it it does the same thing
with corporations Stonewall is a
disgrace pink news is a disgrace these
things should be defunct they do not
speak for me they do not speak for Julie
in fact they attack people like us and
my point is we do not have the situation
as gays of
take me to your leader
that's the worst one the take me to your
leader sorry these weird malfunctioning
inadequates who pretend to speak for
people they don't know have no right to
speak for a community they don't even
understand and that doesn't in the end
exist that's what I mind